okay what can we talk about last night's
the masked singer because Tommy Chong is
the pineapple man I mean come on I am
addicted to this show so you better
believe I had hosts Nick Cannon tell me
everything he knows the member of the
comedy duo Cheech and Chong was unmasked
as over seven million viewers watch the
man is in his 80s
it was super impressive are you in a
band yes dad
the singers interview voices are
disguised and their identities are
hidden from the celebrity panel and even
Nick so I'm surprised I do not know
you're the executive producer I had the
choice at the beginning uh-huh just they
said do you want to know and I felt like
as the host that would take away you
know I wanted to find out when the
audience found out with 10 secret star
singers remaining I gave Nick our best
guesses as to who they might be
[Music]
the rabbit is Joey Fatone why that's
what we think why why not
the poodle suzanne somers you never know
I know that dears Terry Bradshaw why
because the way what I know Terry
Bradshaw there's a few people on the
show that are purposely changing their
voices to try to tell people
I'm with you I think that's Terry
Bradshaw yeah I do I wrote him we know I
love the show slimy I came dancing over
over
[Music]
[Applause]